all right ladies and gentlemen we're
back back again back again with another
reaction video this is Gina
Avery Austin this is God logic
apologetics y'all know what this is
logic
and we are reacting to Guess Who Dr
Zucker Nike soccer Nike the Christian
Destroyer the Muslim lion the one who is
undefeated man undefeated in the debate
World against the Christian faith
interesting he is their hero so we're
going to react to him and see what he
has to say to this nice lady here
um and if he speaks the truth if he
speaks with authority
um hopefully we don't get the the same
you know little um
give me one unequivocal book one
unambiguous statement in the entire
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
them in success I am God or worship me I
don't want that I just want I just want
some truth let's see something
all right all right let's go
Jesus is the word of God met flesh but
religious mind is too big for five
senses every messenger gets the word of
God Moses was the word of God Jesus was
the word of God Abraham was the word of
God Prophet Muhammad is the word of God
so what is the problem is
the word of God what is so different
about Jesus peace be upon it you cannot
point out a single statement from your
Bible where Jesus said I am God over he
says worship me don't support that sir
still the beginning of the word of the
Bible till the time of Jesus tell me any
of the messenger you call who was
capable to cast out Devils to heal the
sick if a person takes out Devils from a
person does he become god sister there
are many human beings
[Music]
devil from the human being that does not
make them God does it make them God they
got that power from Jesus I'd cast out
Devils myself in the name of Jesus also
you also become God now no I have been
translated
faith in Jesus
[Music]
Zucker Nike Dr Zucker Nike did you hear
what he said about all the prophets when
she said Jesus is the word of God do you
remember his response that they're all
the words that they're all the word of
God Moses was the word of God Jesus was
the word of God Muhammad was the word of
God all the prophets in their time was
the word of God
I only have two words for that response
show me
I want one unequivocal statement
one unambiguous verse in the entire
Quran or the Bible where Moses peace be
upon him
where Abraham peace be upon him
where Ishmael peace be upon him
or Isaac or Elijah peace be upon him
where they themselves says
I'm the word of God
I want one unequivocal statement facts
though
I want one why is this man lying to this
girl like that that's crazy
messenger is the word it's the word of
God
wow show me that I I will become a
Muslim today
I'll be coming when y'all see this video
whoever comments in the comment section
you give me one unequivocal statement
from Muhammad himself where he says I am
the word of God I'll become Muslim you
give me one unequivocal statement from
Moses Bible or Quran where Moses says I
am the word of God any anybody else in
the Bible or Quran any Prophet that says
out of their own mouth
unequivocal statement I am the word of
God I become Muslim today
wow that's that's
wow words for that wow
that's crazy okay all right so that's
that's that what about when he uh did
you see how he misrepresented her when
she said when she said that you know
people are casting out these demons or
whatever by the power of Jesus yeah I
have done that also by the power of
Jesus and he clowns her and says oh so
you become God yeah and they all laugh
because they're so they're so ignorant
they're so uh mentally good good good
we're doing good here praise the Lord
carnal minded uh any response obviously
he gets a clap any type of response he
gets a clap and they all clapped yeah
when he was naming up they all clapped
all of them clapped when he said Moses
is the word of God Muhammad is the word
of God they all clapped blindly in the
blind man man they all clap I wonder if
there was a single Muslim in that whole
entire uh Stadium or wherever they were
or even who saw all the thousands the
millions actually 2.5 million views the
millions of people who saw this video if
there's any if there's one Muslim who
said uh Dr zakar Knight that's not true
that's not that's not where it where
it's where that's what it says what
maybe they've emailed him and he just he
deleted the emails ignored them that's
funny because I'm like
that's true
even if that's true so
even other statements by other people
that so-called The Messengers are the
word so is the word not true is the word
truth when they say Jesus is God or
Jesus is a partly to the Son of God and
all that type of stuff because they're
the word of God
so that means that word is true right so
I'm just confused of it all I'm confused
the whole thing is confusing so all the
prophets taught that Jesus was God
Isaiah being the word of God taught that
Jesus was God Moses teaching that Jesus
is God and so that's what I'm saying we
can't believe them but we can't believe
that yeah that's correct we can believe
Moses and Isaiah and all the all the
messengers before Jesus and even after
Jesus we can believe in him but
we can't believe Jesus no you can't
anything that says Jesus was God are in
in that give that concept of an idea a
perspective oh we reject that but we
believe everything else that's crazy
yeah cherry picking for anybody who
wants to see how to prove to a Muslim
that Jesus is God in the Bible I did a
video on this it's going to be linked in
the description probably somewhere up
here on the screen I don't know if I'm
gonna put it up there like that but I
did a whole video on this on how to
prove to a Muslim that Jesus is god
um and how stupid their criteria is when
they say show me where Jesus himself in
the explicit exact words I am God
worshiped me where he said I am God
worship me uh how dumb that actually is
because I would love for a Muslim to
show me where in the Quran where Jesus
said out of his own mouth I'm the
Messiah
one unequivocal statement
one unambiguous verse in the entire
Quran where Jesus peace be upon himself
says
I'm the Messiah
that's what I want you will never find
that
interesting you'll find the Quran
attesting to that and saying that
claiming that he is but Jesus himself
never makes that claim in the Quran
that's interesting yet they believe it
that's interesting but they have to come
to our book our Bible and say well Jesus
never said the exact words I am God
worship me so he can't be God so it's a
double standard it's a double standard
interesting it's a double standard
so now if if of course it's very
dishonest now if we put it in in the in
the if we attack this now and I let's
say there's clear ways you can claim to
be something without saying the exact
words like for example I love this
example if I say I have students and I
give them lessons what am I a teacher a
teacher did I say I am a teacher no no
but you understood very clearly
right simple and plain yeah so if I say
for example I give eternal life who am I
claiming to be God if I say I'm the
first in the last who am I claiming to
be if I say I'm the lord of the Sabbath
who am I claiming to be God okay so all
of these statements that are clear if I
say I am that I am who am I claiming to
be God if I say that you have to on I am
the one who judges on Judgment Day all
judgment is mine and I'm the king who
sits on the throne who am I claiming to
be okay so if I'm saying all these
statements and it's clear that if Yahweh
why to a doctor Dr Zucker knock is it
unclear to you and then millions of
Muslims who see this
you logic
oh my God logic
[Music]